yeah welcome a new 15 minute game and
the poll of this call to machete so
maybe he's a fan of this movie yeah yeah
I just pull up his um his notes and it
says you just beep it with the wrong
mexican which is from the movie anthem
second Claude is some machete don't text
both from the mentioned motion picture
so names oh I go III and I played a
three a couple of times it always feels
very risky in 15 minutes yes but i like
them like to have this challenge
challenge are dropping back i recently
had this in a bits game against some
some i am strange why don't people take
that the idea of the names Oh after all
okay let's select just develop in this
other game i played bishop d2 and Roxy
one yeah the principle to move would be
before of course just grabbing the space
and using the some this moves a three
not sure if it is some reading too much
of course um yeah blackest has lost to
move with this Bishop before e seven
maneuver but it's woody three it's not
the most aggressive set up the Dwight
can possibly play now okay I tried that
and don't particularly like it but that
is a way to to justify the set up this
Bishop t2 moves that I played in the
other game didn't really work out so
well yeah p5 was the alternative
yeah at least I'm able to capture here
in one move this is so something at
least not much but something
okay so
can't the question is what do I have in
this position after all if you care if
he if I castle and he plays Bishop d7
I'd be 27 west by play only 45 I could
go d5 here and I'm wondering if this is
maybe maybe an option t5 it takes d5 95
yeah maybe maybe okay that's so nuts
castle first
I think d5 was was too early for
instance black could have taken and
maybe play Bishop f5 just allowing 97
aha but this makes d5 much more
interesting because he weakens the light
squares like c6
yeah don't know this also might need to
simplifications and a good game for
black but what I can go efore why not
efore him yeah this is good in fact just
grabbing the center and he's got
problems with the creating counter play
how does he get some play against my
center Bishop to be seven has got but
also I'm a problem with it if I just
cover it for rookie one Queenie too he
cannot play c5 anymore because I take
and be 7s hanging so the bishop to be so
amorphous is probably not so great but
white is intending to push be five and
then directly d5 and this looks really
ugly he 594 my detector the e5 pawn it's
difficult to make a move in the khaki
can try c5 of course immediately but
then he must be a ready to counter a 45
with some good news and I don't see one
at the moment rain maybe you have maybe
he needed to do that it's possible if I
he will probably go nite reform yeah
it's not too bad
you have no gee form
but if I go if 594 on C txt for at some
but I have queen deform whereas this
night going okay let's let's do this
first he needs to go 94 now otherwise I
just played d5 and blanket gets
completely busted so takes on c5 and d5
cannot cannot be a be playable he needs
to go to g4 I guess and what to play off
the 94 even aged three years own so move
well yeah I thought this this wasn't
wasn't playable really maybe I'm
overestimating my position as possible I
thought it takes on c5 and d5 and it
looks it looks really really ugly the
immediate d5 is also i'm also possible
the the the problem might be he takes
takes d5 night b6 attacking the bishop
i'm not sure that i am have such a big
big edge then therefore the the instant
d5 is also on something to consider d5
takes on before and then a night move
like night b5 yeah it looks very good
for white but is it is it winning or
leading to a big edge ya don't know
looks looks really really dangerous is
there some some other idea
d 5c takes before
I could even play d 60 interesting
hmm Jim
huh d5 instantly FC takes be four might
be five or 94 before I can play 95
problem
and I'd be five threatening d6 but maybe
you can even take on d5 and it's not the
not so clear if whitis is really a
really winning okay let's let's go for
this I cannot calculate this and now in
such little time I guess the only moves
as she takes before now I mean you you
you don't need to look at anything else
and at least I got that one right I
thought about d6 even the straps the
bishop on on his heaven but them it
doesn't look too too promising so I
guess night b5 must be all 94 94 he's
got night to see 5 and this should
should help him I can think about taking
only six take ecigs takes c3 taking on
f7 then taking on f7 King h8 and i get i
get the piece back all night be 50 95
you
takes Queen takes and then e6 mmm yeah
it's probably good it's probably good
for white to some extent but not quite
sure how good I think I'm he needs to
take am I'm threatening a d6 and and
just win material so we need to take and
now I thought Queen takes attacking the
rook this was the idea and then e6 is my
next move
so my thought them run along the
slaughter group b 8 down I don't think
he can play a very heavily okay five
they are you he can and just did 46 me6
must be the move on is there something
else 94 night deform also also on night
c70 some possible move
e 6 you can play nighttime matrices
seven maybe hmm tough 97's on anyway but
ok I probably don't have don't have an
alternative anyway the n97 may be in
this position and I'm in the somewhat
awkward pin
now 9750 yeah maybe taking an Queen age
five okay he just grabbed wrap the poem
yeah this is the weird what was he
thinking about Brooke f7 it's not so
great hmm ok so how to continue rocked
you on pinning not sure this helps 97
assess the problem move and also the d7
night bad news the playbook t1 maybe he
can play even Knight f6 self and rope
dat should be six it's it's not it's
nothing special how to make sure that he
cannot move maybe okay the discoveries
are problems so I could pin on 97 rock
d1 he can play night the naija shame
okay maybe this move preventing night c7
and asking him what move are you going
to play now maybe night be a tour or
some some weird stuff he doesn't have
many forward moves maybe 95
yeah Quincy six maybe wasn't wasn't so
great rookie one I could have played
rookie you want this would have been
interesting just attacking the bishop
and winning a tempo developing the
rookie out there maybe locally one
awesome move yeah this is a position
where you can forget all yeah general
consideration considerations it's just
one hundred percent calculation of lines
and if you make some crucial mistake
with with your booty or calculation than
you have then you're done now probably i
already made this mistake but should be
7s very very uncomfortable to face i
forgot about 95
yeah the queen is some strapped after
Bishop e7 I don't don't see a move
maybe 95 / should be seven night g6
takes Queen takes and then I'm
threatening queen age five now this
looks looks utterly ridiculous to be
honest what may be
I'd I really don't see another idea I
mean hey as mentioned probably just
nonsense but didn't see something else
if he thinks for a longer time now I'm
getting really really wondering if this
is a cheater I mean the only player
moves is takes on g6 why spend seconds
he's only playing I'm sorry I only
playing 15-minute games and nothing else
yeah you never know it just feels really
if you've got only one move why spend
spend any time just them just move
instantly okay so Knight f6 don't really
have some idea Queen yet Lissa is the
defense that that he might come up with
rook be 32 h3 this would be nice but the
Snyder so this is the the the annoying
piece
Queen f5 to h3 maybe yacon need to play
move down to two minutes but ok this the
time is so the only thing is if I maybe
get some some kind of some kind of play
against so against the king
yeah I'm upon die i'm a timepiece done
that's not nothing in sight in terms of
compensation
yeah really I I don't have even even a
threat coming
try to get the night d 5 f 46 something
like this the the only very very very
modest hope sir is this 95 mph g6 I
don't really understand but it's
probably a it probably doesn't matter
much pion can't even play um yeah I can
play Bishop g5 I can then exchange it
take be six at the end okay oh why
didn't the cruciate dead
so I'm what what kind of position is
this got three pawns it's got only one
pound left for an extra piece yeah well
the King position I mean maybe he's got
something very very direct down some
direct attack or something otherwise
this isn't so easy tech firm detector
from technical point of view
hmm yeah maybe this this is probably not
so not so bad even I mean I don't really
see how he wins
yeah no it's just a drawing I mean play
h5 and get rid of his last poor next
move ok maybe you can can get some kind
of a tech but this can even be tricky
for black if you if you don't pay
attention so just take it
yeah I'm down on 50 seconds so we will
continue and doesn't even can be called
unfair because he's got this okay i
blundered the porn when I was thought
about this
yeah I'll silly to blunder the pawn
rating would would have been much much
easier with two points then then with
one pawn
check
check
check
check
can never take on that 522 Luke f 7j
oh this is nice 20 seconds would have
been impossible to to make the 50 moves
down okay I was certainly I was lost and
but this also means he I'm sorry for for
the for any claims that this might be a
might be an engine otherwise an engine
just just kills you in this position
this isn't this isn't so easy really I
mean what what's rukon be 70 something
and the knight on d5 coming coming on d
5 2 F form it's difficult the only has
got this this single porn it's not an
easy technical task what I did is I I
spoiled the huge position here but this
is just completely misplayed by black
but I didn't really I didn't really ever
use it yeah the computer wants to take
twice on c5 and claims the big advantage
which is probably huh which is maybe
right because life is so passive cam
went to see only here he gives white an
advantage here as well but probably what
I did now was wasn't right came here
here I don't really know what to do I
off Bishop b2 is the the engines the
engines suggestion this was a lemon
ready yeah Queen and the night to be
eight I feared that in the game this is
even better here became but this also
winning would like this is just the the
last kind of hope like blackest winning
here with all kinds of moves I mean this
is bad okay but
didn't you didn't refute it of course
here 93 is plus 6 mm okay yeah and now
we get this end game and this isn't
clear I mean it should be a very good
for black probably winning with them
with perfect play but just one pawn this
is the issue and while two nights cannot
meet a single King and so on so it's
it's just this one pawn and this is your
home it's difficult maybe this is this
is decent even in terms of hoping for a
draw the only thing has some that the
piece coordination this isn't so great
at the moment but the way it did went in
the game it was it was good again I mean
now then the night is coming to to d5
and and I can advance pawns to make sure
that the last part is exchanged and
India why doesn't even worse
yeah here Ruby A to B 7s the easiest
draw and this of course it is a drawing
even if I give away the two points i can
draw against a look at and bishop it's
it's not so easy but it sets it's doable
this time fifty seconds sir okay yeah
thanks for watching interesting game